so this is for cliff so you mentioned I
think you mentioned this on talking dead
you said there are bad asses and sad
asses on your show so how would you
describe it seem like Travis was having
trouble coming to grips with the fact
that horrible things needed to happen in
this world so where is Travis now is he
sad ass or bad ass Travis is very
attached to his idea of honor and moral
code and he's probably the slowest to a
debt but I think we're gonna see things
happen in the next half of the season
that that might shock our audience what
Travis is capable of and I think it's
gonna be a badass dad that's the that's
the new tag badass dad well is he did it
was his decision to go because Chris was
becoming a little unhinged by the end of
the season a little bit some stuff you
know I like to think that maybe he's
right maybe that Chris is just ahead of
the curve a little bit too far maybe too
extreme but maybe we all have to go to
that to come to terms with others to
survive in the apocalypse I don't know
if standing over your sleeping family
with a knife is really the best place to
be but do you think in light of that do
you think that's part of the reason why
Travis went off with him do you think it
was not really as much to protect him
but to protect Madison and the rest of
the problem yeah absolutely it was the
honorable thing to do you know we're
having a problem with our son and it's
like somebody has to give him the
attention he needs to try and help him
to adapt the you know he just lost his
mom and he's not getting the attention
that any normal teenager needs to feel
like he's loved and taken care of and I
think is the right thing for a dad to
take that time now go camping with her
son or whatever and try and figure out
how to help him
you know I mean perfect time for a
camping trip perfect time but we should
just ask Lauren Lorenzo how what do you
think is happening with Chris we're just
going on a camping trip no we're just
going on a journey um no I mean you see
you see this vulnerable kid I mean he's
had such a terrible life these last
seven episodes and he has such bad
circumstances that just all factor into
him
you know leaving and getting away from
everyone and you know grabbing the knife
and getting out of there
well did actually this goes into a
question for talking dead calm was that
do you think Chris was really gonna stab
Travis at the end or was he just
posturing I think it was just giving his
dad a little tease you know that you
know what don't hang son I need
oh no he wasn't gonna kill Travis just
give him a little love it felt like
you're gonna stab me you like swinging
that knife in you you knit you nearly
hit me wasn't gonna happen
now you guys should work it out on the
camping trip I'm kind of wrestling by
the way everyone smile every time we
catch them they're just sort of sizing
each other up it's amazing
wherever we go it's really adorable the
entire time that's their dynamic in life
but Madison there's definitely something
going on with Madison then we don't
there's there's crazy [ __ ] in her
background somewhere and I mean she's so
on top of stuff she seems so adapted to
this world so quickly and even it is
kind of this mentality of like whatever
needs to get done and so was killing
celia was that indicative of a madison
that we're gonna see or more stuff that
we're gonna see with her I think you
know I think Madison when I read the
script it shocked me that that happened
and then and then I was just I thought
it was the coolest moment and the
coolest line for the character to cross
you know so and then when we played it
you know when we acted it Madison just
sort of it looked like it felt like
something just overcame her and without
thinking about it it's what she did so I
think it is indicative of what we're
gonna see and this side of her and but I
also think it is indicative to of like
where she's come from what her life's
been like yeah but is it weird for her
that she killed Celia to protect Nick
and then Nick leaves her such a slap in
the face right it was like that's like
the gravest action and now she's a
cold-blooded murderer and it still
didn't
she still can't protect him I think it
means he's lost to her now do you think
she trusts that he'll be able to take
care of him said cuz it it does seem
like you know everyone's been so used to
protecting Nick his whole life and
protecting him and getting him out of
trouble and in my opinion he's the best
adapted person in this world right and
so does she does Madison really
understand that or does she still feel
like oh I got to protect them or can she
really let him go and figure it out
I think her her you know primitive
mother instinct wants to still you know
still thinks of him as a child who can't
who needs to be protected but you know
she has no choice now but to let him to
let him go and it's interesting because
I found moments in the scripts later
where Madison had learned from Nick some
things so I guess since Frank's right
over there do you think Nick has given
up on his family at this point or is he
does he just need to figure some stuff
out I think you can never give up on
your family how I think you just need
some time alone
well Nick Nick Nick well you get to gunk
yourself up basically you figure it out
pretty quickly in the show that if you
gunk yourself up you can kind of move
invisibly through the walkers which it
seemed like he seems very comfortable
with being able to be this invisible
person among the dead what's the gunk up
process and is it fun or is it miserable
it's really miserable because it's very
sticky and it's always when I first met
denies character she sort of had the red
blood a bit more just sort of dabbled
over her face and I really went for it
and I think like hell Boyle's ever when
we shot that initial scene in Episode
three where you were he was underneath a
walker and stabbed up
literally there was a gallon of blood
dumped on your head yeah I don't think
the shot ended up in the episode but we
were like okay we gotta get him covered
with blood and there was a torso at the
blood bag in it and you stabbed up and
it was like one second it was clean the
next second you were just completely rad
and your mouth and your eyes so we're
like well we kind of got a match to that
and then we took the shot out of the
episode so next time you kids
Sofer Alicia
since Madison and Alicia have
essentially been abandoned by Nick now
and they've always kind of protected him
like I was talking about with Kim how do
you feel like she's gonna deal with this
is she is she equipped to deal with this
at this point or does she feel does she
feel let down I'm all the way over here
I but her I think it almost feels like a
fresh start in a way there's this is
something that's been going on her whole
teenage life that tension has been
boiling underneath the surface with
Madison and Alicia for a really long
time and now I'm seeing that Nick has
finally made the choice to really leave
and that there's no possible or truly
plausible way he could just reappear I
think for her it's like okay well maybe
now Madison will focus most of her
energy family on Alicia and also her
just finding her kind of like being
groped coming into herself and and being
seen as an equal finally - in that
dynamic because I think there's an
interesting mother-daughter relationship
that we definitely start to see change
in the second half of this season very
much so who by the way I'm kind of
racing through this sort of clip because
there's a lot to get through and I want
to make sure we have plenty of time for
audience questions so that's why I'm
kind of bouncing around really fast but
this is from talking dead calm who can
you always count on to crack up during
the scene like who is that it is are
there pranks there's someone break what
who is that Coleman
oh my god Coleman call me we go I think
I may ask just on the show but did
strand love Thomas or was Thomas
necessary for him to was he and I liked
it I like that I think the writers you
know be Dave and the writers I think we
all sort of want to make it on leave it
to the audience I think I know that
strand his sort of value with people was
more about obligation and but then I
think possibly I have my own little
secret that I think that possibly just
before probably in the moment when he's
screaming Thomas when he gets there I
think probably he realized he actually
really loved him yeah it probably was
one thing and then turned to something
else and then it was over
that's what I think so how would you
describe his relationship with Madison
at this point well he's got the hots for
Madison like formidable characters right
I think that we two people probably look
at each other in the beginning and think
they have nothing in common but very
strong ideals and personally in the
clashing and but then you find that they
need each other more yeah I think they
recognize a familiarity and each other
and they start to sort of work off each
other and learn from each other and
become sort of an unlikely Alliance and
then they might get drunk later
Travis is sitting right here I'm good
there's a lot of medicine to go no no I
think I think I think I think the thing
was strand was so fast nervous character
is like Travis cannot stand the man he
doesn't appear to have any morals or
value codes that that Travis can
recognize but every time strand has been
there for us and he has saved us at
every point strand of his word yeah and
then and then when Travis chooses to
leave to look after his son in the back
of his mind he's thinking strand will
take care of Madison and that's and that
there any hopes that there is something
honorable there blended factors we're
sailing we're sailing close to the wind
we don't know how things would work out
but and I think that strand is emerging
I kind of think Madison's taking care of
strands at this point yes I think
they're I think the characters are very
similar and that they're both survivors
they have different tool sets to do that
but they're clearly both will do what
needs to be needs to be done yeah we
complement each other absolutely this is
for Dave Erickson so there's a new cast
member joining Danai Garcia who's down
at the other end what what can you tell
us about her character and how she fits
in
danai plays Luciano and it's off of what
you said earlier it's it's Nick when he
leaves I think he is on something of a
spiritual journey he's sort of playing
off of what he learned from Celia and
trying to figure out what is his place
and the apocalypse and why is he alive
and what what are the dead and I think
what he finds as he heads you know
towards Tijuana there is a Colonia
a neighborhood outside of the city and
he arrives in this you know he meets
this you know group of people who don't
have the exact same belief system as
Celia did but they don't see the the
dead as a bad thing necessarily really
see it as you know just in evolutions
the next step and Luciana is sort of
this sort of badass soldier in this
group you know and somebody who is also
an orphan of the Apocalypse in the same
way that Nick is by choice and the two
of them you know they form they form a
bond
so I'll asked I last deny what sit
welcome to the show by the way welcome
to comic-con yeah so what's it been like
yes what has it been like coming into
the show you know second season joining
the cast becoming a part of this so
quickly well it was it was amazing I
happened so fast I I got the job on a
Wednesday I was in Mexico on a Friday
and on Monday I was on set it was that
fast and it was not just a normal job is
they fear the walking dead job it's just
not normal and I remember just driving
to set it was a an hour drive and I just
fall asleep in the car when I when I got
there he was in a minivan they opened
the door and he was lunchtime and all I
saw was walking dad's everywhere
eating lunch just hi
just like oh my god amazing so we're so
it was incredible and joined this family
it's been amazing so how how would you
describe with Yana and and her
relationship to Nick at the beginning of
this part of the season
well she's testing him I mean he's the
foreigner this is my land Mexico and the
one that La Colonia has his rules and
the way the Mexican culture deals with
the dead is very unique I was doing
research being in Cuba myself I I
learned that there are three kinds of
death for the Mexican culture the day
you die the day you get buried and the
day you're forgotten in The Walking Dead
you're not buried and you're not
forgotten because they're in your face
so they certainly deal with them in a
very constructive way it's the way to
evolve
pretty much and within that mindset
their rules and the rules that Nick has
to has to pass hopefully and I put him
to test with that she just puts him in
his place
until he passed that test with gore you
know so a lot of stuff through talking
dead comma through the Facebook page
people were kind of saying oh something
going on between Nick and Ophelia is
there's something there or is you know
or is or is Cris kind of angling like
what what's happening and now that
you're separated from everyone how how
do you think a philia is feeling at this
point I mean we've all been there long
distance relationships are really hard
you guys Nick went off on his own behind
I think a philia and Nick had a really
good connection I think there was
something that bonded them about being
really pure the two of them saw the
purity in every situation and I think as
they're progressing individually I'm
really curious to see when Nick sort of
comes back to the fray and when they see
each other again how they've
individually changed and if that's gonna
bring them together or if that's
ultimately what makes them realize maybe
they aren't going to be together so but
what do you think Frankie
couldn't possibly come in do you do you
think Ophelia has finally accepted
what's happened ever parents no okay but
she was one of the last I think she was
even a little behind the curve than
Travis in terms of not really processing
this world and still hanging on to hope
that everything was okay so do you think
she's ready to accept what's happening I
think she doesn't have a choice at this
point I mean she lost her mother she
survived a gunshot she by all means in
her account has lost her father so she
is an orphan and you know what they say
about orphans they're really badass
because they have nothing to lose so I
think feeling has gotten to a point
where either she's gonna crumble or it's
gonna make her really strong and I think
that's what this this next second half
of season two we're gonna find out is if
she goes one way or the other but I
would just like to hint I mean when you
have nothing to lose you have nothing to
lose so then you can make some crazy
fatalistic decisions this is a question
which was if you could write your own
ofili a fanfiction what would it be like
it would be all an interpretive dance
there would be lots of butterflies you
guys would be there yeah no I would just
want to see her sort of pull a little
bit of a Carol like you know have her
start as a little meek larvae and then
blossom into like a really violent
butterfly which you can catch with 600
Wow you know like one of those killer
butterflies you've heard of those
Shirley
you